[Inaudible].
I do my best work, uh, with, uh, quite a bit of noise,
some music typically, or some type of cafe restaurant environment.
I'll give two, uh, one is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
Fantastic, fantastic fiction book with an incredible narrator.
And this is water by David Foster Wallace to the commencement
speech, the book, or listen, that has been most influential to my own path.
I would say are the moral letters to nucleus by Seneca,
the younger, I have read all those letters.
I would say several dozen times. What do I like most about storytelling?
The ability to ride a wave of
imagination, to the extent that I lose track of time.
If I had to pick one thing in fiction, plot, character, or setting,
I would choose character. I think that is the connective tissue. Realistically,
I would probably narrate my memoir and just, it's such a specific genre of book.
It might be strange to have someone else do it,
but otherwise I would have to go with Neil Gaiman, even though I'm not British.
The guy's voice is just so hypnotic and incredible.
I write always for myself
or a few of my closest friends.
I'm never writing for a general audience. If I had to define it,
it's probably number one.
The simple answer is living in such a way that you'd like yourself.
If I had to add to that,
I would say it's probably some combination of achieving what you want and also
wanting what you have least favorite sound is any
device at high volume on an airplane,
but some kid is using cause their parents are parenting by negligence,
little judgy answer, figure in need one of those.